like
well it's six after nine and uh are we
on we're rolling are we wrong
i heard glenn come in but he's just
he's he's slow and everything the start
time was nine o'clock
was the start let's look at the text
chain here
welcome to the podcast david this is
what it's fine um wait wait wait wait we
have a special oh david wants to decide
wants to do a reveal here he goes there
he is we're not rolling it oh yes we are
come on we're all
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast glenn will be joining us
whatever he [ __ ] feels like yeah wait
a second charlie is here and meg is here
on time are we starting early oh
we're starting early here comes glenn
fuller
because he's late because he's late
because he's late hey meg what time is
call time um i look i don't want to get
involved
you're the producer what time is it what
was call time i uh amara what was call
time you know what hang on
it's fine it's fine yeah when we say
nine we show up around nine you know um
we were all here around nine
you know one minute after my call time
but before we totally make this about
you uh i've noticed there's another
person in this space i was trying to
give him his due but glenn walked in and
ruined well that's no you guys did that
all right let's start over welcome to
the podcast everybody
special guest in the studio today oh
there's some he's used to this kind of
bickering because he's known us for 20
years now if you're listening you can't
see his face if you're watching
you can't see his face because he has
turned the other way
ladies and gentlemen
if you haven't guessed by his strawberry
blonde
[Laughter]
and his
ladies and gentlemen sandy duncan sandy
duncan
oh yeah well no i i get that a lot but
well and sandy duncan's going gray so
that makes sense too because in the back
it's
a few points where people don't know who
sandy duncan is anymore i was just about
to say that for you listeners and and
watchers out there you're probably gonna
have to look up sandy duncan yeah what
was she most famous for besides playing
peter
peter pan right peter pan yeah peter pan
yeah broadway star but really the hogan
she's brought into america's living room
by the hogan she was a replacement right
yeah for valerie harper she have a glass
people don't know what that is either i
mean but most people don't know what
we're talking about she's got a glass
eye yeah yeah she had a glasses wait
wait do we all know someone with a glass
eye though like does everyone have
someone that they know from their
hometown that's like oh yeah they had a
glass yeah
but but how often was it glass or how
often was it a lazy or wandering eye
that kids assumed was a glass it was
glass because why wouldn't it move yeah
or whatever why does it matter it was
framed a different way yeah sometimes
sometimes the eye moves at a slightly
different rate like it one moves and
then the other one catches it has to
catch chunks ears from goonies
like
mine
what a disturbing choice in that movie
to be like i think we're going to make
the ears just wiggle to just terrify
kids for
yeah anyway david's here
buddy hey hey good to be here good to be
here nothing worse than a uh podcast on
video
[Music]
are you in full hair and makeup today uh
no no no hair makeup yes well you look
great ran a brush through it yeah yeah
nice brush but you've been hitting the
dermatologist your skin looks fantastic
no no nothing nothing just you know wake
up and just just
live with terror and fear most days yeah
some sort of anger and uh it just i
don't know maybe just kind of comes to
the surface okay it just seems like the
anger doesn't come through oh good good
oh well i actually don't think you're an
angry person
you know you can get angry but i don't
think you run hot right there's a
there's a level of uh there's a level of
anger underneath i i've often said that
i think a lot of comedy comes from anger
i don't know if that's i don't think
that's the case with every comedian but
if you don't have any anger i don't
trust you at all
you know what i mean like i'm suspicious
if you're too nice yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and you have that that
southern reserve the the texas like
you're holding back
and i get that from time to time it's
the boots the boots they contain you you
know what i mean they
you're wearing a high-top sneaker which
is the boot of sneakers
the boots the sneakers i believe it is
charlie you dressed up for this time i
wore a little sport coat for david and
some ratty jeans and my uh t-shirt with
the banana on it that's the velvet
underground um
and uh
another thing that nobody knows
now did these pants tear naturally or is
this this is a natural knee tear yeah
because they do the rest of the gene
looks
i've been if you look closely at the
podcast i have worn them most every
episode and uh as i tend to do um i blew
the crotch out of these had to get it
fixed oh man and i love the crotch right
now
that's it we ran we saw chad coleman
this weekend at comic con last week oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah you gotta have chad
on the pub gotta have a chat on the
podcast yeah but for now we have to yeah
david let's get all right
we really should get chad though
much better
yeah
let's go let's go david
right now i was actually remembering
with chad a moment from uh
from one of the episodes where he does
the the jean shorts uh where he he talks
about the jeans the let's get weird one
where you guys we're all over at the
party and you gotta take them off every
now and then yeah yeah exactly and then
we were rehearsing i remember he he had
not he didn't notice no for some reason
there was a monologue that's that gene
monologue and i was
when i saw him at comic-con i was like
do you remember that like the last time
i saw you i feel like we you were i was
like oh and you got that funny gene
monologue he's like what are you talking
about i'm like you don't you have a
monologue like right here it's in the
scene that we're rehearsing is like yeah
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] okay i gotta go but he's also
not like chad at all like he's uh he's
like a theater actor he like comes
prepared like sometimes over prepared i
would argue and yeah he was no i feel
like it's more like us like whatever
department was in charge of sending him
his materials probably like oh really i
don't know but either way it's just like
he memorized it right before we did it
and it was it's it's in the canon now
i used to have some jeans shorts like
that too
they're slapping them shits man
eventually i blew the crotch out of them
things but you can't wear them every day
in the spec form to hold up
some nice ass denim too i missed them
shorts
but you you got to take them off every
now and then
you got to take them off son and you
know what it was it was better because
sometimes sometimes like i remember i
think i think chad because he didn't do
a lot of comedy before he started
working with us like was a little
nervous about it and he would like
really prepare for it you know we we
because he was in boldly going nowhere
which is well david hornsby
with uh david hornsby and uh
you know so it was kind of nice to see
him slightly unprepared because then he
was able to just kind of like follow his
comedic instincts which i think but
that's an actor's nightmare right when
you show up and you're like oh you have
a monologue you don't you don't know
that that's literally going nowhere and
uh always looking for content and and i
don't know that other podcasts have done
things like this but why don't we just
put boldly going nowhere out on the
podcast
and have people watch it
david's be on youtube really i i don't
know is it not yeah yeah the biggest
problem is
my biggest issue with boldly going
nowhere is the sound
uh because like
we did a sound mix and for some reason
the final sound makes the the the the
the score was the score was too low
yeah it was like you almost you almost
can't hear the score so there's like
scenes of like
just dead quiet like just dead air
and we literally added in because of the
spaceship we thought like it sounded too
quiet when it was quiet so we added like
a
like a hum yeah sure there's like a
uh-huh
underneath so you can everything
everything sounds vacuous yeah yeah
everything sounds vacuous yeah yeah
nothing's better for comedy than vacuums
i finally got a new mattress in my room
oh my god you would not believe the
rigmarole i had to go through to get
that thing but it's really helping with
my my back problems
oh tracy
i miss sleeping next to you
don't you just want to grab each other
and just
be wild and just roll around together
that's three easy payments three easy
payments of 2633.
how are the kids
can you hear me i feel like you can't
hear me yeah kids oh did they get that
picture i sent of me posing with the
blaster let's just look at how hey
where's the money
i sent the money are you not getting the
money and it's not enough lance the kids
need more it's not enough it's
it's practically everything i'm making
up here the other dad send more money
well i'm trying to send as much as i can
i mean i need a little money surprise
okay well you're letting the kids down
so tricolor uh where are the kids i want
to say all those little rug rats i don't
know whether okay well but real good
then okay
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa what
was that what was what
the i thought there was a gentleman in a
towel that walked by uh-oh huh
oh i think i got a weird connection i uh
i'm probably going behind some kind of a
moon moon are we oh can you not hear me
looks like we gotta go let the inspector
guy on board after all so oh okay babe
we gotta go oh she's gone come on must
have a bad connection are we going
around a moon no there's no moons where
we are my show is cut now
listen right this way sir this is the
ship's uh temporary holding facility
where we house the various perpetrators
we have on board
what are these people being held for
exactly well you know
leaving your clothes laying around for
somebody else to trip on disagreeing
with the captain being a punk-ass [ __ ]
that kind of thing all i was doing was
just chewing gum yeah
but you were smacking it and driving
everybody crazy being all loud
i say we've made a couple of pilots
maybe and nobody's ever seen them and
maybe that's good
but maybe we put them out there and see
what the people think well who doesn't
swing a mitch miss much
[ __ ] i just
swank swung
right in the middle of my sentence [ __ ]
it forget it
i was just trying to spit it back to
david man let's go let's go all right
part of the talking about bully going
over because david's so great in it but
there's another show he's also great in
it's always sunday in philadelphia you
missed the quest
[Laughter]
look i brought some i brought some
things in case
you know uh we got we got in a lull oh
you brought a topic you brought
you know it's like like things that i
thought i might say like that i had
prepped for my own like ted talk if you
ever you know would you like to say one
um well i i can if it gets in a lull
okay well then let me let me try to
understand this we're gonna hang out
with these cards i don't know i kind of
feel like we're
we're in the nosedive but uh you know
what we'll just put a vacuous sound
underneath all of them we should do that
i want to take you guys to 1997.
oh take me there baby i don't i don't
know it's western massachusetts yeah
i've signed up for a summer theater
festival
there's a young man there at that
theater festival
his name is david tiberius
close enough hey what is your mail name
alex oh yeah yeah that's right
yeah
yeah okay david allen grew up i did want
to change it at one point to kirk when i
was a kid after kirk cameron and i did
my mom said you know i'm thinking about
uh changing your name because we just
kind of named you and i'm thinking we
should name you after your grandfather
he's just kind of named we just kind of
like threw it out
[Music]
yeah like 10 or something i don't you
know somewhere around there and i was
like oh well actually this is perfect
because i'm thinking about changing a
kirk would that be cool
and why kirk like because he is the
coolest kirk cameron on growing pains
yes was the coolest not so much anymore
yeah but uh you know he took a little
bit of right turn yeah yeah right very
very a very right turn yeah yeah
a very self-righteous turn yeah yeah
this is what i i don't want you to
confuse that moment for a lull let's
let's let's get back into that okay so
the year is 1997. david hornsby has been
cast as has charlie day in a little play
called
johnny on the spot oh yeah uh who was
johnny
neither of us are johnny so you know
somebody else got johnny yeah yeah we
weren't even in the spot though
yeah
uh
sky wolf wasn't there that year yeah
sure but uh no this was uh
christopher reeve's wife was in the play
i forgot her name was diane yeah yeah
dana
and uh james jimmy john
famous broadway actor acting and
directing it always very uh very easy uh
interesting when you're directing a play
that you're also starring in yes i
forgot he was directing it yeah uh and
we were i was like a sign holder or
something like come in and be like uh
you know they're really buying signs
today or whatever like like one line
you're a signed seller yeah something
yeah maybe a signed seller yeah i don't
recall do you remember what your role
was i i were you in that play sure was
pal
you sure he was the scientist no or not
you were not in one of the other plays
and it was like
i was in one of the other players too
buddy i was that good but
i was in johnny on the spot you weren't
joining the spot do you remember when
paul newman came by i do remember when
paul doesn't continue wearing it okay
because i was doing rehearsal paul
newman came by [ __ ] slinging salad
dressings charlie you had the stuff
he did yeah yeah yeah didn't tell me
that wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait paul newman
told you that you had the stuff the
whole other thing this is not my thing
this is david's thing i was talking to
the catering person
and they were like yeah i got the stuff
here's your applesauce mr newman yeah
yeah yeah he was like he was like [ __ ] i
need a beer and he's like anyone got a
beer and he's like he's got the stuff
you're like
yeah i got it
here you go mr newman um you're gonna be
great one day yeah
i was in the play but i had like one
line in that play okay okay i had more
lines in the play that paul was at
rehearsal i don't remember him at the
rehearsal i remember him at the premiere
of the show i do remember he said when
someone made a joke or something he he
was talking about i thought it was
really good you know i thought in blah
blah he's like i don't know it's all
budweiser up here you know and we were
all like yes
he's funny too he's funny too
he's referencing his uh functional
alcoholism
in an amusing way
i'll be late to that 30 years
but uh i i remember i didn't we weren't
buddies yet
you're an admirer yeah i was a myers fan
i was like here's a talented guy
and i remember picking up your you had a
you know we would have these books of
compact discs
and you're probably like getting sick
logic sure no one knows what that is now
either you're getting psyched up for
like the play you know listen to your
tunes yeah and i was like oh cool what's
that like a boxer before the match yeah
i'm like you mind if i flip through and
it was like you know
the opera les mis
like all these songs like oh i'm not
sure calm wilkinson solo album yeah yeah
liz callaway
and i don't know that we hung out that
much that first year that probably put
you off for a few years it put me off i
was we are not the same oh it's like oh
he's like one of those guys and then
uh
the next summer we both auditioned to
get in the next sort of level up in the
program and we were in a company
together where we're spending like the
entire summer together doing sort of
like avant-garde theater
and i found out that you were the
funniest man on the planet
and dick as thieves ever since then
that's right yeah that was 25 years ago
which is pretty crazy
yeah it's a quarter of a century guys
yeah yeah so fast forward uh
fast forward
through that quarter of century to the
point where we're making the pilot of
always sunny and i was i want to back up
a second i want to tell you about the
time i met david
okay okay okay okay
did i steal your thunder no no no no no
do you remember the first time you met
david because i had a similar experience
to
to meeting david as mary elizabeth did
because and you which is at first you're
like i don't know about this guy
i don't remember mary elizabeth's i
don't remember the stories but okay her
no her point of view is if she didn't
know if she liked you she first and i
was i was the same because you you seem
very persnickety mm-hmm
fussy can you just um just a little just
your hands a little closer yeah like
today i met david you remember this
david
was that uh a taping of a little show
called the louis guzman show it was
called louie
and
um my friend charlie yes my friend
charlie
was in this pilot it was on the fox lot
i had never seen a television show shot
before i thought this would be cool you
didn't come to that eddie show i was
never invited
i don't think we were friends yet we
weren't friends yet no okay no
but i think you had a similar experience
to me where you were like i don't i
don't know if i'm friends with i want to
be friends with that guy with david no
with me
oh with you oh yeah
definitely no you are you you're like
i worry down um so david said so david
uh
i meet oh you're also friends with
charlie oh great this is really cool
we're at this this the taping of the
show where they try to keep you excited
and a very air-conditioned live audience
laughing live audience
and in between those who don't know uh
in between takes or in between scenes to
get the crowd excited they have a warm
up warm-up comic right and the comic is
there to just to jazz people up and get
them laughing keep the energy going yeah
just pump up that crowd
and so the and he the guy was doing a
pretty good job everybody's excited it's
going to be a big fun show and they say
okay great now we're just going to wait
for a few minutes and get everything set
up and david says great and he takes out
a little book that he has a big book
yeah a big book i believe it was the snl
book not yeah they just come out okay
behind the scenes like a tale of two
cities
what a great book a great book fantastic
book david starts reading the book
now he's sitting are you sitting next to
him i'm sitting next remember yeah
near him next to him because i remember
the guy
the david just starts reading but he had
an option to strike up a conversation
with his
you know mutual friend of charlie day or
nicholas nickleby yeah that was that
wasn't the weirdest part the weirdest
part was just being out in public in as
a participant in an audience and just
yeah right
and reading
it was down time right just to be clear
we were sort of between setups and he
was kind of talking to the audience he
wants candy you know he wants to perform
for candy yeah that kind of thing yeah
there's stuff there's nothing like
animals now this stand-up comic is like
hey man
can you put the [ __ ] book away it
comes up to him so yeah can you put the
book away but how many people are in
this audience i mean a hundred a hundred
it's a it's a rather large audience yeah
right but he singled you out because his
whole job is to keep the audience
focused and i remember the guy saying
i'm gonna get fired like i'm gonna get
chewed out because my whole job is to
get you to focus on what's happening
there and not what's happening in the
book why are you here i can't go back to
the left hud
i can't go back i gotta stay a gig here
man they bring me in that's friday and i
remember david now
in that situation i i don't i don't know
i was like oh [ __ ] like he's getting
dressed down and i remember david's
response was
no
yeah whoa so nice
yeah i was like seeing it man well
then the guy was like dude just [ __ ]
put the book away and the more he got
like aggressive with david the more
david was like i'm not putting my book
away i'm going to read it he said who's
your friend hey i said he said what are
you doing here i'm like well my friend's
in the show i'm here to see him he's
like who's your friend what's his name
i'm like i'm not telling you yeah i'm
not telling you i don't have to tell you
anything i'm like i'm sitting there
watching this
i love this guy now i'm like now i know
i want yeah yeah yeah yeah i put my
readers back on
open my book up thank you very much sir
yeah yeah and and to to be to david's
credit it is like a four hour long it is
an endeavor
it's an endeavor no you were the first
person that was like i think acting on
well i don't know at that point but but
it was like oh this is exciting one of
our friends is on a show like let's go
see it yeah in front of a live studio
audience yeah you celebrated by reading
a book in the middle of it however
i don't i still don't think that's weird
i'm like okay so you want to read a book
and some down time i i still find it
bizarre and i i to me i i'd stand up and
defend it sorry if you talk with
somebody will you bring a book just in
case no conversation but i'm not sitting
goes to the bathroom you bust your book
out uh is it anything different than
looking at your phone yeah and like
scrolling and reading something no it's
not it's actually better
anyway i was i was i was definitely
interested in becoming friends with
david although he kept me at arm's land
for a while well because usually when i
meet someone i'm like oh is this jerk
yeah i gotta do you know that's the
first well but was that because
that's kind of your your initial feeling
about anybody you're like yeah i gotta i
gotta figure out who this person is and
you know for me i've got yeah they want
something from me
they want to emotionally connect with me
and i'm not i'm not and i'm not into
that i don't need that right yeah enough
i need to keep him yeah he's like hey
i'm robin i got enough going on what
that's the first thing out of your mouth
yeah
okay man charlie's brandon
i left my own man
[Laughter]
no i totally remember that and and it's
uh yeah i don't think it's that bizarre
but um but it definitely is uh it's
definitely a a sign of character
certainly if you were to write a
character you would be yeah
for sure it tells you
how to tell the audience how do you tell
the audience about this character
without exposition yeah and so that was
20 years ago and i think i think the
lesson we're learning here is that
people don't change
no absolutely not oh no we're all so
we're all exactly the same we grow
we learn we become more wise but we're
pretty much the same people we've always
been i i don't remember uh i think my
first the first time i ever saw david
hornsby i had heard about david hornsby
was when we were shooting our our haley
joel osment uh frankie munez documentary
mockumentary and uh you and jimmy
simpson played a married couple yeah and
i remember haley's parents well sorry it
was haley's parents yeah yeah
and i i i distinctly remember
it was i i wasn't even there when you
guys shot you for some reason i wasn't
there yeah you shot separately yeah yeah
i met you at that point yeah we hadn't
met yet yeah so the first time i ever
saw you in my life was was when you guys
were showing me the footage of what
you'd shot with with david and jimmy
first of all right off the bat i was
like
amazing and super funny that instead of
having a man and a woman it's just two
men and one man is playing a woman
and and then i i just did the woman was
it jimmy yeah jimmy played the one
that's so good and i distinctly remember
you eating a glazed doughnut and
drinking a budweiser
oh yeah and thinking that's a really
funny choice in and of itself like
the the the combination of sugar and
alcohol must have driven you crazy
and i do remember thinking like this man
is both these men are extreme i knew
jimmy at that point but i was like that
this guy is also really really really
funny and then i think we probably met
honestly
the first time we shot something
together i feel like i remember meeting
you at like a bowling alley like we went
bowling remember bowling we used to go
bowling for fun nice social lives yeah
remember sticking your fingers in a
random ball you know that everybody else
thousands
no it didn't matter and guess what we're
all still here yeah we're all fine yeah
i met david at my interview for sunny
yes david conducted my interview for
sunny myself and scott marter yeah
that's right yeah david and scott uh
interviewed me and i had to pitch
a storyline uh to him and i was very
nervous because i had watched david on
sonny for a long time
and uh but he was very nice it was a
warm room yeah yeah it wasn't too
intimidating they were they're very nice
um i mean they weren't like overly
generous but i i that would make me more
nervous if i was like oh they think i
need their laughs and then he must have
given me a good review because then i
ended up eating all your jobs i ran into
rob's office
i found her i found her
yeah do you have the shoe come see how
we put it on here
i'm wearing
i won't take it off
she can go find her own shoe with that
[Music]
we're brought to you in part by shopify
now let me ask you boys a question are
you afraid of scaling your business can
i be real with you yeah yes
and can i be real with you too
what is scaling well honestly the best
way to do it is is shopify honestly i
mean shopify gives entrepreneurs the
tools that a larger operation might have
so upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere you
know synchronize online and in-person
sales and effortlessly stay informed oh
i love that okay so shopify makes it so
that any business can succeed from down
the street to around the globe oh no it
already powers millions and millions of
businesses i mean from first sale to
full scale plus you can reach customers
across social networks like facebook
instagram tick tock pinterest and more
seems like the real deal here it
absolutely is so go to shopify.com
sunny all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
sunny right now that is shopify.com
[Music]
this episode of the always sunny podcast
is brought to you by
mcdonald's per meg's request
yeah yeah you see i'm a details person
as you know and here on the podcast we
like to dive into each episode of sunny
in detail but you know what else is fun
to discuss in detail i'm guessing you're
going to say the mcdonald's crispy uh
chicken sandwich bingo are you more of
like a standard or a spicy or even a
deluxe all right here's the thing about
me if you know me you know i love
anything spicy okay that's that's easy
for me now i know i'm a deluxe guy now
whenever caitlyn and the kids are out of
town i go get one by myself and then
i'll watch myself eat it in the mirror
and i'll be like yeah
yeah you're doing this you're doing this
bud and you love it well look there's an
absolute time and place where nothing
will suffice except a good old-fashioned
mcdonald's crispy chicken glory so
what's the right answer what crispy
chicken sandwich build is best every
single one this is making me very hungry
about lunchtime and i i want that
mcdonald's crispy chicken sandwich you
order a head on the mcdonald's app and
try the sandwich that invented crispy
juicy tender today app download and
registration required
[Music]
now meg were we planning on watching
some of david's highlights yeah i've
made a super cut of some of cricket's
best moments so we can watch the
de-evolution of cricket over the years
it happens fast it does um and so the
the curve loaded up
from normal to
cartoon insane
not real i do remember noting
how incredibly
grounded your performance is in the
very first episode that you're in the
miracle episode i feel like that's when
you're like uh for me like that's when
your young actor
i mean i'm not saying it's it's better
or worse but i'm saying young actor like
all right i want to just
i'm not going to bring any kind of angle
to this just perform like when you go to
like like uh you know acting school and
you're like i'm going to perform this as
sincerely as possible you know and then
as you
find and as you keep going you're like
oh i got to kind of bring something to
this a bit more but i feel like like
acting school you're like no do it as
neutral as possible like i was probably
in that mindset as well i was always
afraid of being too big right exactly
that was always my biggest fear like
don't be broad yeah and then and then i
would see other people do stuff that was
big but didn't wasn't broad and i was
like how do you do that how do you how
do you do something that's like really
intense and big and
you know boisterous or whatever and and
have it not be uh you know feel broad
you put a pancake on your face what's on
the page though right like you couldn't
do that first episode of no matthew mara
big and broad no he's a straight man
he's a grounded kind of guy who takes
his religion seriously and then you know
star on sunday you're probably the
straight man you know the most of the
time yeah all right all right go here we
go here he is oh wow what is you
2006 six we were in physical therapy
together twice a week after school you
look the same you look exactly that's
very upsetting
physical therapy with you
i wore the giant leg braces oh my god
yeah with the leg braces
in high school rickety cricket dude
that's right rickety crazy
[Laughter]
oh my god
forgive me father for i sin that has
been 10. i remember this was a uh just a
box in like a warehouse stage or
something and it's like i don't know
what part of the stage it was this was
in um what was the name of the hearst
building or something oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah downtown herald examiner
alexander yeah this is one of my
favorite scenes with you david because
it gives you just like a little prop
business with the door open which you're
so good at like just utilizing just so
well the timing of giving this guy any
business
one of david's great talents is
uh miming you know so like when you're
in a writer's room with david he will
pretend to like eat a sandwich or
something in a very detailed and
hilarious way i had a runner where we do
the food bit where it's it evolved from
like eating a sandwich but then it
became like eating something and people
try to guess what it was but doing it
very weird like if i had like i would go
like
and you're like
where you're just going
was an apple you really kind of seem to
scrape your teeth yeah you're scraping
off the he's scraping the corn off the
top yeah he's scraping the red carpet
i got that yeah yeah yeah yeah i have a
good bet listeners at home are loving a
good miming video
i want you to know something i love you
what
some doorbells
you forget that she's just
right wasn't she like trying to win a
bed or something no no i think she
actually feels the things right well she
heals it right and then she has it and
she doesn't feel anymore yeah exactly
once she gets it she's like oh
oh no i don't want it i actually wanted
it i just wanted you to want it
what are you doing here i thought about
what you said and i think you're right
in some weird way this was god's plan
for us i mean i had to become a priest
to reconnect with you and i had to leave
the priesthood to have you
huh mr reynolds i'd like to ask for your
daughter's hand in marriage done
so that's the thing about danny
this is the day i met him for the first
time yeah i think i was like do you
remember what that was like i i it was
very quick it was like you know shaking
his hand sort of and then i'm in a scene
with him all of a sudden and you're then
he says something like that and you're
like oh my god this is
that's amazing yeah done
so good timing
did you just say that you left the
priesthood yes
yes i had to matty wow you should not
have done that what do you mean you
better
you should go and
undo that right now
so you don't love me oh
maddie okay you are a great guy
why don't you go back to the priesthood
i can't okay i i
i can't you can't just go back dee yeah
i want to become a priest again you
can't okay but but are you sure did you
did you double check that oh my life's
ruined that was season two
um
so you were already a writer then so
were you like involved in coming up with
like what cricket's
character was gonna be or did you come
in as an actor and then join as a writer
or like he wasn't he was there we didn't
have a staff and he wasn't like on the
staff you we just second season no i i
wrote a episode second season cricket
came about because
well i helped out on the you know the
pilots of the the shooting
early on but then i remember charlie was
like hey we have like do you want to be
on the show we can we have like this
guest spot you could do season one here
um i think we're at your house like at a
party or something and uh i'm like or do
you want to it's not like that big you
want to wait for something bigger
and i was like uh yeah wait for
something bigger so
he offered me something but then i don't
know what it was but uh and then you
came back you're like we have something
for you uh and you have you guys have
come up with it completely you know
we're gonna call rickety cricket yeah uh
braces you're you know what the first
thing which one is that i don't know
yeah the first thing is probably just
some straight man guest guest thing that
was like do you want to be the guy at
the bank kind of idea but totally oh the
first thing but so then the second
season
um so at the same time i had sold
um a show and you guys it's like at the
same time we've the other mall yeah we
both worked on stuff separately like i
had helped out with your thing but
uh
i had sold my own thing and then you
guys were like guess what we sold you
know sonny to fx and i was like oh
that's awesome i guess what i just sold
this pilot to fox and you guys were like
oh [ __ ] that's way better that's like
yeah that's real real tv that's real tv
yeah that's the major leagues yeah um
it turned
yeah it worked out it worked
guess what i own it all [ __ ]
um
going back to the the luis guzman uh
multicam that i did you also did one
called the mullets
yeah yes that you were yes my name our
la we wore molds and we had mullets and
our last name as well was that after the
manchester
sure yeah he wore bullets in your last
name
see that's why when i said that i was
thinking well maybe i had already done
it before
all around the same time this well
obviously the second um
like episode
we filmed for the like pilot stuff
before it was a show for sunny was a
show i was like the joke was i was the
famous friend because i had been on the
market because no no
six feet under oh really yeah we were
stoked we were stoked to get you because
you did three episodes of six feet under
yeah
yeah yeah actually can we just talk
about those early days a little bit like
uh
you know the fact that uh when we the
very first version of the home movie
rob didn't want to be in it he wanted to
just write and direct
and uh so you played uh the character
rob
like
like do you remember or is there
anything you remember from those early
days that i i remember yeah well i
remember he didn't want to be in it and
asked me to do it uh but i and i
remember filming it and being
feeling like i didn't quite get exactly
sometimes what you guys were going for
you know like it was very much your
sense of humor and obviously you should
have been playing the part like but i do
remember we went to a nail salon and we
told
you guys set it up we're like we're
going to snail salon and we told them
we're like filming it for your birthday
or something yeah he said we said it's
it's our buddy's birthday we're we're
we're we're just doing a whole day where
we're treating him to all these
different things and we're filming it
all and you know we want to have him get
his his nails done his uh tone is he
want to get him a mani patty for his
birthday and we're going to film it and
they were like
fine you know yeah you're just trying to
we're just trying to if we needed a
location that was always the you know
you had to hustle and eat that you're
either paying someone like hey can we
film here and like we'll pay his money
or you lie to them
yeah do that kind of [ __ ]
people
you know there's people giving you manny
patty and
you know we're doing the same shot over
and over and you're saying the same line
i'm answering answering the phone and i
say go for jesus
but i feel so uncomfortable in in the
situation it's almost like you never
sometimes just didn't quite get it
you're like because i just hey go for
jesus
like you know i'm like looking at the
cow no um and but i do remember the
scene in the um coffee shop where you're
you are uh no you have cancer and rob is
copying you to study you
and not quite getting the right like
comedic quality of it and then
the second time you guys were gonna
shoot it um
because you persevered you know you got
some no's in regards to like it didn't
look good you guys shot it again you
wanted to do it again rob called me up
and uh i couldn't do it at the time and
i was like why don't you play it anyway
like
uh and so i remember when when i saw
that same scene you guys re-shot it i
was like oh that's
right i get it now you know
so i i kind of remember it being like i
also remember wearing a sock on my penis
[Laughter]
you come out of the bathroom and i'm
trying to get you to examine my foot
yeah or was that only that's what we
yeah because i've got like uh
redoing it but you stayed in your
underwear or no we just cut that scene
yeah we put you in we put you in a
tighty tighty whitey kind of situation
and and uh yeah yeah yeah the career
always starts with the sock over the
penis oh that was oh that really
no but that was where did you get your
shot came from yeah that's right did you
get your shot mr producer
did you get it
okay
that's our running bit
[Music]
david
about
uh
like it was just the three of us in an
apartment
and i was like david i mean it says in
the script you're naked so i guess you
gotta get naked
again uh maybe this is it's we're it's a
bunch of dudes and we're friends it was
not an abusive situation but no but then
he was like well how am i going to show
my ass like when i turn around
you're going to see my dick and i was
like i'll shoot above it and he's like i
don't trust you and i was like i
wouldn't need it
i wouldn't either
that's smart
so he puts a sock on and then
we shot it and i stayed above it because
he wants to see a sock and then
afterwards he put on a robe
and yeah we were like all right you good
he just turned to us and goes did you
get your shot mr producer
[Laughter]
i remember at six feet under they gave
me a rope because i'm supposed to be
making out with uh michael c hall in
this in the bed and they someone like
came in before like after rehearsal and
they're like here's your robe and i'm
like thanks
am i oh do i get naked what is this i
don't know what's happening you know
like no one broke it down for me yeah
yeah um and uh so i like i'm like all
right we're in the house in the valley
and i'm like i go into the this bathroom
and i change into the robe and i'm like
do i do underwear do i what what what is
this and i get into the robe and i come
out and uh there's no one there yet like
it's still and i'm like in a like a very
like fine thin robe just feeling like
in the real life oh yeah very very thin
robe and there's no one to joke about
that you get your shot just more like a
cold harsh like reality of like yeah
what am i doing and uh i was like you
know what i'm gonna go back in i'm gonna
wait till someone says get the robe on
um and uh change back and never had to
wear the robe just just took off the
shirt but uh
as those those moments you know yeah
those before um
what do you call it
which is great because it is amazing how
often it it like any kind of sex scene
was treated or nudity was treated like
like you would when you're a 14 year old
boy everybody's like afraid to talk
about it everybody's like giggling even
if it's a good set there's no
conversation happening and like if if
david even somebody like david is
intimidated about what he's supposed to
do imagine like a younger person who's
totally on set and it's like well he was
a younger person that was what what i
mean what year was it yeah 2017. you're
probably in your early mid 20s right
yeah here you go
put it on gorgeous
would this sound gorgeous yeah yeah do
you guys remember we had an intimacy
coordinator on mr quest because we did
an episode with some sex dreams
and they asked because there's one with
your two characters uh having a sex
stream and they asked if you guys wanted
an intimacy coordinator and you're like
no we're not we're good we're good
that'll just make it weird
yeah yeah
have we all done all done the uh the
[ __ ] sock on on sonny i do i've
definitely
all right that's right yeah what did you
do
like it's like the 80s movie sex scene
thing and so it's just
oh and quarantine when he's like oh no
he had underwear on them
hey i got an idea
should we look at your very last clip of
david just to see the oh just the full
thing in that
so bad just to see what that's a good
idea how different that is that's a good
idea actually yeah i like that
all right
that's good it's like there's no real
hair or face left it's just everything
from the breeze to this guy with the
milky eye where did we land on the
cassava i i think you can eat it man i
think we're done with it yeah we're done
yeah oh
yeah baby yeah
i would have needed cricks
i think he was i think you were actually
i was unavailable you were unavailable
yeah you big-timed us yeah yeah big-time
danny devito it feels good big time a
guy like danny devito doesn't yeah yeah
yeah i might be playing the lowest low
but every now and then get one in you
know get a shot in
allow me to introduce
[Applause]
okay
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i can't just jump out and do a reveal
like he's he's a good 15 feet ahead of
me so i really gotta yeah yeah what the
hell frank where's mac max out why well
i think he's going back in the closet
god damn it you had one job get the gay
man to dance on the head it's not that
hard we got a problem we got a problem
dennis doesn't want to drive now he's
thinking he's claustrophobic under there
what is cricket doing here because frank
blew it oh come on man you had one job
that's what i said cricket's gonna do
the dance dance qriket no no no he's oh
god no come on man he looks like a
monster this one i fasted for for a
little bit all right i did the are you
trying to lose a little weight because
i'm like i got to be in my leathers you
know
you're going to be you're going to look
good in your leather you got to look
good in your leathers yeah yeah oh my
god and thank god you had that outfit at
home because like we would have been
screwed like we didn't we didn't have it
and so dave was like i got it
i have something that might work and
then
i was in the trunk of my honda
i just stopped by rough trade
i'm not going anywhere until i see an
abraham lincoln
there you go what is this what is this
like 73 cents no i i said abraham
lincoln there's a bunch of lincoln's in
there oh those are pennies okay you want
to give it back to me hold on i love
that you you fasted for this even though
then you put lesions on your body
like you're like i want to look good but
then there we go
right right ringworm i want to be true
the character you know i wouldn't i
wouldn't be you know i wouldn't have
extra i wouldn't have that extra
oh qriket's going to do the dance dance
qriket no i mean no oh god no he looks
like
why don't we play one from um this
season from
last very last season oh i don't think
we have i don't think you were in i
don't think yeah
you know what that's right i wasn't in
it yeah
i want to talk about that
and it was a really good season this
year it was great you know
one of our best kind of put it back on
the rails in a way
i'm just starting to see you maybe
budget wise because you didn't have to
do the makeup but otherwise
i'm going to do this there we go ptsd
yeah so with the burn face if you
remember we we burned the face and then
we talked about the face being a little
too grotesque i want i wanted it to be
full like half a face freddy krueger
yeah like freddy krueger half face and
and i was like i and i i didn't see a
problem with it you guys were like it's
really disturbing to look at and i'm
like yeah it's [ __ ] amazing i think
yeah that was one of those things we
could not agree on but you guys were on
the same page i wanted it to be as
grotesque as possible i can't remember i
don't remember that yes we softened it a
bit with the notion that well it
probably healed over a little bit over
time yeah sure it would heal some
oh we ready to party tonight
[Laughter]
uh they took out the kidney actually
that was the first time that i really
thought hey i might actually uh
i might die
[Applause]
dark blue marble we colored all right
anyway anyway it seems like the type of
thing that they just wouldn't even
script for you they'd just be like yeah
just like start telling songs
we just made it up announcing it i
remember robbie you know
and uh and he'll be he'll turn right now
he'll just show his what i
is what he pat what passes for him for
an ass uh and
it's like insulting my body for everyone
it's fine it's all part of the show
you gotta fake it like don't trust me no
one will even know i mean on the streets
you gotta fake you know what i mean if
you're orgasming you fake it you know
the guys that don't fake
listen
what do you mean you don't thank you you
don't you don't know you're laughing no
no don't worry about i can sell anything
you know you know how many times i fake
on the streets
the orgasms the o's you know
you have to fake the guys that don't
fake they're the ones that get it the
worst
there's the guys that don't survive
so i faked
so that the rape lasts a shorter amount
of time too sometimes you don't fake it
well sometimes well sometimes you don't
fake it
because it's so good
well sometimes you don't fake it okay
and it just ends
naturally
okay
[Music]
quick it's like anything we can do to
have you not talk about like sucking
penises or getting raped in the body
i honestly don't know which part was
scripted where we started breaking off
from it but
pretty early on i don't think any of
this stuff about faking it
i think the faking thing and then we all
saw an opportunity there just kind of
kept going
uh a whisper conversation is always
funnier than the full volume
conversation yeah yeah
yeah that was that was a funny day on
set because that we found that riff and
we just could not keep a straight face
that scene and then maybe the lemon
scene we were breaking up there yeah oh
for sure the podcast scene oh we could
not keep it together with you doing that
sucking on the lemon and be like
yeah maybe we should just be watching
the bloopers from david because he made
you guys laugh so much here we go this
is the actual scene yeah i love the
scene i i love this thing for you guys
really though three wars
two two two there's gonna be something
surreal about doing a podcast while
watching this scene what was the premise
of the podcast that you guys could just
be as interesting as uh on the radio
well i think i think at the time we i
think we were
like probably
thinking that podcasts were kind of
stupid you know it's basically like the
average person thinking that they can do
what people do on the radio and be just
as entertaining and being like
and you don't even have to resort to all
that dumb [ __ ] all the stupid sound
effects and all that kind of [ __ ] like
we just need to have an interesting
conversation we'll be ten times more
interesting than those personalities on
the radio
which is what we're doing now
[Music]
okay all right well um listen let's get
into the issues here we're gonna start
rolling on this oh no no no i am not
saying another word until i get the
chicken i lied about the chicken friends
oh my god unbelievable i don't want to
trust you
i do have something for you
lemons lemons yeah you just [ __ ] them
crackers
he's got crackers
so this is the first lemon scene that
we've ever introduced lemons yes
here we are talking about the homeless
issue here in philly that's a big issue
these days and we're here with our
friend cricket he is a homeless man
qriket
walk us through a day in your life
oh day in the life
well uh the other morning i wake up i
find a dog sniffing at my wound he's
fully aroused mind you
your
the reactions of everyone is
he's looking at me right in the eyes he
does not have to say it
not that he could
[Laughter]
[Applause]
i mean does my scar look like a dog
vagina let me see it turn it over this
way yeah i mean maybe it does maybe it
doesn't i don't know i'm not gonna sit
here and try to get inside the head of a
dog you know that's not my job that's
god's who doesn't exist by the way
[Music]
maybe it does maybe it doesn't i don't
know i'm not gonna sit here and try to
get inside the head of a dog
you just lay there and you let this dog
do his business this guy could be feral
you know what i mean they have that on
the street
that's good stuff this is a great uh
david this is the gang cracks the
liberty bell did you write this episode
too yes i think you did write this one
yeah i wrote it uh i was trying to
remember if i wrote it with like martin
roselle but no uh
yeah i wrote it and um
did you write them spitting in your face
into the script yes i think i remember
coming up with that me like ah she could
spit in my face because dee spitting in
my face first thing in your face too
because
and then it became a runner and yeah and
i'm like it's one of those weird things
where you like you know what's best but
like
she will be spitting in my face if i do
this if i type this and they're gonna
love it they're gonna love that
it's something where like everyone spits
in my face that's gonna so it's
definitely going in
all right but yeah when you're on the
day and it's just take four let's do it
again
oh
okay
[Music]
okay my face right now oh okay okay okay
okay
that one was in my eye
i'm really sorry that was huge yeah
have you guys all gotten cast of your
heads yes yeah yes it's a very
claustrophobic experience i'm wondering
if i would ever do it again if i just
don't really do that
it's a laser scan though yeah ah i like
to go i weirdly liked it i had to get a
cast in my head for uh the strangers
because i got half my face blown off in
that movie appeals to quicksand
fantasies
oh yeah do you want to be smothered is
that what we're feeling we're hearing
we gotta smother smother no i don't i
don't i like um
it's like uh have you ever had like an
mri is it mri where you have to go in
the thing and it beeps and bloops at you
and you're like in the thing and they're
like
okay just you're going to be in there
for a little while and i've had i've had
it done twice
and i loved it both times i loved it i
loved being in like a little small it's
so weird yeah i find it a little bit
comforting i find it comforting yeah it
gets hard and then it gets really hot
right here yeah they just put like and
they put strawberry straws you really
someone maybe hold your hand you know or
something like hey it's okay just
you don't have the hand holding thing
is that your wife that provided that
service they're just a random nurse
this is just looks like a prop random
prop guys
hey buddy don't worry
are you sure
he shows his hand
[Laughter]
extremely hard that is a hard thing
spitting on his hand
is this a real prop house
oh yeah david never showed up here
yeah i went the wrong door
just poured clay on your face and then
had you jack them up
hey guys my name is david i'm an actor
um sag obviously uh i feel like a lot of
people
and it's just your face like
you're live cast yeah oh yeah you guys
are gonna pour stuff on my face and yeah
you're gonna do something in my head oh
yeah we sure are buddy
what are you doing
from a musical i'm writing a musical you
guys it's about life on the streets
archangel has to live on the streets and
fight crime what's great where are our
drugs all right
good give us some money
spent the money on these sweet ass
kettle drums look at these those are
trash cans trash cans oh these are trash
cans uh they're like might sound like
this
[Music]
[Laughter]
garbage can no no no no no no as if
cocaine's like a
crazy hallucinogen i can't commute oh
don't do all of it though because i
still gotta write the seventh act it's
kind of all up here cricket come on back
to the box i'm not going anywhere
without these kettle drums all right
bring your trousers yeah don't forget
the trash can don't bring in a trash can
they will cut you that's a pop that's a
pop that's a car oh this okay this is i
mean this is
some of your most iconic stuff yeah this
is frank
gets commented on going out i'm going
guns blaze
rise up gonna get higher
no rob rozelle like i was thinking was
doing that bit in the room
higher and higher yeah did they write
this episode rosella margaret uh yeah
yeah they were they were a big part
yeah so that was definitely fed to me uh
by rob rozelle and is uh hilarious but
you got to make it sexy i think is one
of the most like enduring gotta make it
sexy yeah yeah yeah nips and yeah i feel
like the specificity of a rotisserie
chicken felt roselle yes you know what i
mean yeah yeah like lemons like or yeah
or martyr you know but like those two
guys
looking good bro thanks man i'm almost
done you guys you got to make it sexy
hips and nips otherwise i'm not eating
there it is big pink necklace big pink
nibbles let's talk about those nips for
a second yeah have you ever have you
ever tried to figure out what size coin
fits on your net
i don't know i haven't no have you not
mm-hmm absolutely yeah is that a thing i
don't know no it's not a thing i i i uh
uh that's that's a weapon
so you die a dime size dime nips
get this
surprised by that no i i joke about it
because like jill joe jill used to i
don't know jill used to say like you've
got dime nips like she would always say
that and so one day we took a dime and i
was like let's just see like if a dime
isn't and it was exactly
eisenhower daddy are we leaving
daddy's daddy's measuring his nips with
a coin honey i'll be right there
just give it just give us a sec
i'm gonna do one right now and this is a
product that i genuinely genuinely love
athletic greens i've been taking my
athletic greens ag-1 green powder
literally every day charlie you say you
feel so great
and renewed after you take it it's given
you
somewhat of an alter ego uh-huh yep
yeah the guy's called greens man
right he emerges now after i've had my
morning scoop of ag-1 with 12 ounces of
water he just kind of takes over
like the hulk the hulk looked like he
was like he was doping right but green
man is all about staying lean yeah well
look i i imagine it helps that ag-1 has
less than a gram of sugar yeah no gmos
and no nasty chemicals or anything
artificial actually this is very
inspiring so like we said to make it
easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one-year supply of immune
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com
that's athleticgreens.com
sunny to take ownership over your health
and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
[Music]
well there are so many cricket scenes
that we could watch and we have watched
a few but i also have some fan questions
to ask you something oh i'm so curious
about david's note card so i don't want
to yeah
um
if every day is a gift then open up your
present and enjoy
well what's your question no these are
these were like points i was going to
make a ted talk okay great
yeah i wasn't listening what was that
create the netflix algorithm for life
what do you want to see on your home
page
yeah good that's good i like that good
stuff this is just because people tune
in to hear yeah
like reflect on like wisdoms
this is a learning podcast stop
parenting your kids
and start kidding your parents
i just feel like sometimes they just
rearrange things yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah whatever the backwards is yeah yeah
yeah
that's about i mean there's more but you
want
a yeah market in your love life
is a bull market in self-reflection
i can't i can't sort that it's time to
look at yourself yeah
yeah got it yeah i don't know
i don't know enough about the markets so
were these to create a lull or to fill
one
what are some things what are some
questions yeah fan questions let's go
find questions
did you get a lot of similar ones and
this is
yeah and i averaged them out into some
of these questions that i picked my
favorite um what's been your favorite or
mo most bizarre fan interaction
working on sunny
probably the time someone showed me
their tattoo of me on their ankle wow
i'm sh i'm sure you guys have had some
interaction where someone is
maybe through the internet like posted a
tattoo of something but on the internet
to someone
i feel like i've seen them live before
but maybe i haven't at the premiere when
we had fans come and it wasn't just like
industry people remember that year yeah
it was great uh the there was a bunch of
people in the bar
afterwards in the party and uh
this dude showed me his tattoo what
phase of cricket was it it was uh
fourth season 13 when i'm you know got
the the the tin foil and i'm going like
that you know
oh yeah yeah maybe like when dxd's
pregnant kind of area i thought that was
quarantine
oh no that's that's the pcp joint
yeah
did not think anyone ever get a tattoo
of me on there oh
i mean a lot of tattoos to be fair it
wasn't like the only one but
uh yeah that's that's the earliest
here's another question um what was
cricket doing during quarantine which do
you remember we had an idea for this
in the room i had i had yeah i think i i
thrived during quarantine yes and uh i
had a uh
what is a rickshaw company
to deliver things and i was running my
own rickshaw what i remember was that we
were realizing that because everything
was remote work that you just put up
like a background behind yourself and
you were able to like have a real job
because nobody knew that you didn't have
a home amazing and so we were going to
play the thing that the cricket actually
got quite successful during quarantine
because having a home wasn't like
necessary yeah i just needed a backdrop
i would think i'd be thriving because
everyone's getting everything delivered
and i've caught everything so it doesn't
matter to me so i'm just rickshawing
whatever and i'm just like i'm i'm more
flush than ever yeah this is usual
[Laughter]
um is there still hope for cricket and d
which maybe is a question for everybody
here
well that's always a chance
if that whiteboard is empty long enough
yeah i mean i guess the question is can
can you have such a journey where then
you somehow come back around to the very
beginning in some way and
cricket and deep get together and and
have a child i don't know
like in a shakespearean way where all
the all the people wind up back with
each other right if we're at the lowest
point of the movie in a sense of the
story is are we going to have a we're at
our yeah
we haven't gotten to the lowest point
yet do you remember what was your
hardest day of filming sunny what was
like the most difficult thing to shoot
uh i do remember that when we did the um
birds of war
uh
i got stuck talking to rob for like
straight 45 minutes
and that was total for real yeah that
was tough he's like he didn't have
anything to do or something and like you
caught me in one of those periods where
yeah he was talking about his future or
something
that was when he was going through his
cocaine phase too so it was like
remember
like digital coins it's gonna be like
yeah and he was like i don't have to
paint these abs on you know and i was
like okay yeah and he's like just cuz
and then and then you start walking
yeah
yeah wait a minute no um i would say
that when i was when we were shooting
birds of war i do remember um almost
fainting weirdly which i've never
experienced in my life
uh i i don't know why but um i think we
were just rehearsing or something did
somebody say something offended you and
you were like
i didn't have my pearls
your corset was too tight i think that
day
oh yeah you squeezed your core
well it happens you know every now and
then sure um i want to look up for the
camera
the robes were too much too hot in the
robes but not there's not a better place
to be if you're going to faint than on a
wrestling mat yeah what i was but i went
to my knees like i think i'm like
has anyone ever fainted for real
i have yes and it that sort of like
closing in feeling where i'm like what's
going on uh but i
pushed through managed to push through
it yeah
national government whatever somebody
handed you a turkey sandwich and got
your blood sugar back up and you were
good to go or what making fun of the
fact i don't eat meat
sorry tofurkey
this joke brought to you by 1985.
next question
is there anything you do to prepare
yourself when you're getting back into
the character of cricket do you have any
like thing that you do to kind of
capture the i do like three and a half
hours of makeup in a chair um
yeah that's about it to get this yeah
you definitely put the most makeup on of
anyone in this show you know it's a big
transformation yeah i think it's a lot
yeah you usually you've committed most
seasons you've committed and grown yeah
you've got to do it now that is true
growing out that beard yeah like two
months ahead i'll start growing it out
like two months before the writer's room
starts
or in the writer's room
well the writer's room's just like two
months ago yeah right so did you grow up
this year
i didn't grow up this year oh
i'm screwed
rick shaw he's in a rickshaw yeah uh
well maybe qriket could be in the monkey
episode you were in the monkey episode
for like a minute yeah in like one draft
yeah yeah and then we realized what i've
already got a monkey
no i didn't want yeah i wanted to be the
the guy that's like oh you're going to
give the monkey then come on i could do
it let me yeah right
and then remember there was that video
of like one monkey gets like a grape
while the other gets uh that's right
veggie or something like that and the
other monkey's really pissed and so i
wanted to be the like oh you're going to
give him a grape and you're going to
give me a lemon that [ __ ] you got to
give us both the same thing
you know
competing with a mother
but um yeah no i do grow out my facial
hair and then um i wasn't going to say
about that i grabbed my facial hair and
that that takes and i i learned that
when i did joe schmoe that they asked me
because i was on six feet under hey this
guy that we're it was like a you know
reality show fake reality show we had a
mark and like he said he's a fan of
sixth generation so we're afraid he
might recognize you possibly can you
grow out your facial and i've never
grown it out i had never grown it out
and um
i was like i don't think i can or in
college i tried to but i i tried growing
out for that and to my surprise like
this full like nothing here but this
full beard grew goatee group so you
don't grow here i can't grow anything
here but so yeah i grow it out for that
and that's why it's always a goatee
because i got nothing else but uh
yeah but it comes in so thick and hearty
there yeah it sure does yes that's about
that's about all the preparation well i
just want to thank you so much for being
on the podcast today and so i brought
you something as a little thank you here
which is this nice oh
we got your bag
come on let's do a lemonade let's do a
lemon bit real quick
let's do it but is there like an actual
paycheck
uh
no i don't think so crick david how
podcasts work does that we don't really
make it so we don't make any money
not for you
yeah like we don't make money like you
don't you understand
the economics of podcasts you know you
come on you you get to you provide
entertainment no but then you get to
promote yourself
[Music]
you're saying hey we can do this without
you yeah i'm just saying
just suck on this lemon right and you
know you might have a job next year
cricket well let's let me see okay yeah
what what's your actual reaction to
sucking on that thing
david hornsby everybody
he's gone
you